attention décollage ce plongeoir de cinq
mètres a toujours eu beaucoup de succès
à dijon mais il va bientôt disparaître
la piscine du carrousel est sur le point
de prendre un nouveau départ
[Musique]
ce bassin en plein air a été inaugurée
en 1952 le fameux de plongeoirs faisait
déjà partie du décor
65 ans plus tard la piscine a gardé son
style et ses adeptes
jusqu'à 1200 visiteurs par jour pendant
l'été c'est une superbe piscine agréable
avec de la place propre donc la
recommande quoi mais la ville de dijon a
décidé de moderniser le site le bassin
extérieur sera rénové et chauffer un
nouveau bâtiment aux toitures
végétalisées sera construit sur l'actuel
pelouse
il abritera deux bassins couverts des
jeux pour enfants un sauna et des salles
de fitness un projet à 20 millions
d'euros
je connais très bien cette piscine parce
que j'y ai passé des centaines voire des
milliers d'heures mais là aujourd'hui il
était temps de pouvoir passer un
équipement à la hauteur de la métropole
à la hauteur des attentes du déjeuner
avec un bassin qui va être ouvert toute
l'année qui va permettre d'augmenter la
surface dos moi je dis oui à une piscine
familiale
je dis non un parc d'attractions
sorte d'aqualand je suis réservé sur un
certain nombre d'équipements proposé
comme les toboggans comme les pentes à
glisse comme l'ex que j'ai vu squash
game enfin voilà il me semble que ça ça
relève plutôt du parc d'attractions et
dans ces cas-là du secteur privé pendant
les travaux qui s'étaleront jusqu'à la
fin 2019 la piscine intérieure restera
ouverte avant d'être détruite à son tour
dans la dernière phase du chantier
les habitués des lieux attendent d'en
savoir plus notamment sur les prix je
pense qu'après si c'est un projet si
c'est privé je pense qu on y viendra pas
pas comme ça j'ai toujours été à la
piscine chauffée de l'aquagym
je vais dans la couverte aussi mais je
me dis bon je suis prête à prendre un
abonnement
mais tout le monde pour un fake en
attendant dimanche 3 septembre pour le
dernier jour d'ouverture avant
démolition l'accès à la piscine
extérieure du carrousel sera gratuit
jusqu'à 19h30 une dernière occasion de
plonger dans le passé
[Musique]